the media push a red-blue narrative that
makes no sense at all on coronavirus
president comes poll numbers nosedive as
his twitter habit continues to hurt him
and the culture wars continue apace i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN your online activity
should not be public protect yourself at
expressvpn comm slash Ben all righty
well I hope that you had yourself a
mildly relaxed weekend we're gonna get
to all the news there's a lot happening
out there from people defending their
houses with guns to the president
dropping in the polls and all of the
cultural wars and all that I want to
start with obviously the big news of the
day continues to be the spike that we
are seeing in many states really across
the country I think virtually all states
except for a couple have seen increases
in cases in Co vid 19 that of course is
not a major shock as you continue to
release people back into public you are
going to see more cases the question is
does it overwhelm the hospital systems
one of the big questions has been
whether the lock downs are actually that
effective because we saw increasing
level of death in places like New York
City even after lockdown also one of the
things that we saw is that when people
get alarmed they go back in their house
without you actually having to tell them
to go back into their house one of the
things that seems to be happening right
now is that in states that are very hot
where there's a lot of air conditioning
being used the rates are going up and
that's because people are going away
from the public places where they were
gathering you know outdoors and they're
going back inside and staying inside so
you're seeing up ticks in places like
California and Texas in Arizona and the
only common thread there is not a threat
of policy it is a thread that has more
to do with the weather if it gets really
hot you go inside inside with a lot of
other people you're in close proximity
with those people and it's easier to get
infected now one of the one of the
things that we are seeing and we really
have not seen a major uptick in death
that's been quite mysterious for a lot
of folks the death numbers over the
weekend continued to be pretty low I
mean meaning that the death numbers on
Sunday across the nation we're actually
lowest that they had been since March
which is pretty shocking considering
that were supposedly experiencing this
massive spike in the number of deaths
across the United States one of the
reasons for that is because the age of
people who are being infected is now
extremely low at a lot lower than it was
originally before it was mainly older
people being sent back into nursing
homes and basically it was killing
everybody off in that first wave as I've
said before
maybe the only thing that you can do
here is protect the nursing homes and
wear masks and socially distance and
that's pretty much it those are all the
things there is not another thing that
you can do to prevent this thing from
spreading and once you have gone outside
you've been with other people well then
there's gonna be a certain number of
infections but there there's some good
news here I mean if the number of
infections is going up and the rate of
death is going down that means the
overall infection fatality rate is a lot
lower than originally was supposed again
the CDC now estimates that 0.26 percent
of people who actually get this thing
and are infected by it are going to die
so 26 out of every 10,000 people get
this thing are gonna die
which again terrible number but not the
kind of number where you can shut down
all Society for perhaps that is
certainly a question worth thinking
about
so whatever whatever the actual overall
number is on this thing we'll get some
more of that in a second the media have
decided they're gonna make this an
attack on red states which is
unbelievable I mean if you follow the
media narrative over the past few months
the media narrative once something like
this President Trump didn't act well
hard enough he didn't act well enough
he's not strong enough at the very
beginning and therefore there's this
vast uptick if it had not been for
presidents from pooh-poohing this thing
at the beginning or Fox News or Sean
Hannity then this never would have
happened and that was sure crap nobody
was calling for an actual shutdown
anywhere in the country until the very
beginning of March by which point it was
too late the thing was already in
circulation New York didn't even shut
down its state until late March after
President Trump had already basically
started urging people to shut down which
was like mid March late March 15th March
16th when you started to see national
attention brought from places like San
Francisco and LA to shut down but even
the shutdowns in LA in San Francisco are
not preventing the spike that we are now
seeing in LA County it's the idea that
Trump was responsible for this is very
silly Ben you saw narrative and the
narrative was everybody needs to stay
inside it was imperative that everybody
stay inside lockdown this thing was
gonna kill you it was gonna kill your
grandmother who's gonna kill everybody
and then there's a gradual release and
that began at the very beginning of May
and for about a month
there was no uptick for about a month
there was an uptick in the number of
cases but there was not only not enough
taking the number of deaths nationally
there was a downtick meaning in most
states it basically stayed stable in New
York for a New York really declined
rapidly
right that was the story of the death
rate from Kovac 19 but the idea was that
those red states were bad right Rhonda's
Hansen Florida was very bad ryankevin
Georgia was very bad Greg Abbott
Texas was very bad all of those places
were very bad because they had not shut
down even though they weren't
experiencing vast overwhelming death
then there were these big protests and
the media suddenly swivel and the median
nerve turned again so remember it
started with this is all Trump's fault
you need to shut down forever then it
turned to well you know actually if you
go out in your protesting for the right
things it's more important for you to
protest in favor of overturning the
American perception of itself in its own
history you need to go on you need to
protest the police go out and do it on
mass no problem you're gonna be immune
it's gonna be fine right racism is more
important public health threat than
kovat 19 and so we saw literally
hundreds of thousands of people across
the United States out there protesting
then the protests end or at least they
kind of fade off a little bit and people
start going out again because they're
like ok hold up a second you just said
it's okay for me to be out so you know
what I'm gonna go out all right you know
you said it we're done and people's
activity starts to change and you start
to see an uptick and now the media's
rage is turning back on the same red
governor as it was 60 days ago when it
was like oh look at this bad around this
handsome bad Brian Kemp and bad Greg
Abbott look at these terrible terrible
red states with their reopening okay
hold up a second they reopen the
beginning of May nothing happened for a
month and then there were a bunch of
protests right right around Memorial Day
and you notice in the media coverage
it's always Memorial Day is really what
set this thing off Memorial Day was May
25th the protests began May 26th there's
literally no way statistically speaking
to tell the difference between an
infection that was initiated May 25th
and an infection initiated May 26th and
the media don't want to know about it in
New York contact tracers have been told
not to ask people whether they attended
a protest so the idea here is that it is
only the reopening but not the protest
apparently if you go to a bar really bad
if you go to an open-air bar where
you're just drinking and shouting about
George Lloyd then fine no problem
whatsoever right not a problem at all
and so we've seen as things have spiked
all of the blame in the media is gonna
go on the red states and it's amazing
it's truly amazing because in the
process of putting all the blame on the
red states that have reopened they're
also trying to rehabilitate the worst
governor in America Andrew Cuomo who
state has lost over 30,000 people now
recognize that to this point the state
of Florida has lost between three and
four thousand people the state of
California has lost something like 4,000
people the state of Texas has lost under
3,000 people last time I checked New
York
absolutely Wallens New York got killed I
mean literally speaking many New Yorkers
got killed and the Andrew Cuomo is being
trotted out there is a model of what a
governor should do well meanwhile these
red states are very bad so CNN showed a
showed a chart and this is just it just
goes to show you the political narrative
the media super dishonest the CNN over
the weekend they show a chart and what
the chart shows from who can see is they
divvied up the seven day moving average
of new cases in Trump states and in 2016
Clinton states what it shows is that the
2016 Clinton states that this massive
spike and then it sort of it sort of
wavered off and then it's increasing
again mildly meanwhile the the red
states what you see is it increased
fairly quickly then it held steady for a
long time and now it's zooming up again
right zooming up again beginning shock
of shocks like near the beginning of
June about a week and a half after the
protests began but we can't blame it on
the protests it's probably the reopening
you see that long period on this chart
if you can see the chart you see the
long period on the chart between the
beginning of May and the beginning of
June where everything is perfectly
stable
well apparently no apparently that
doesn't exist anymore so in any case the
idea is that red states are bad and blue
states are good now this chart is flawed
in about 30 different ways it's flawed
number one because the original spike
does not really take into account the
number of cases like at all like if
you're suggesting that back in March
like late March there were only 30 like
about 20,000 cases daily in places like
New York absolute sure nonsense sure
nonsense so the testing was not up to
par in the blue states overall overall
across the country the testing was not
up to par so it's very difficult to tell
how many positive tests there were in
places like New York like if you believe
that the blue states were only
experiencing twice the number of
positive tests as the red states in that
period and why was it the New York was
hit with 30,000 dead but it doesn't make
any sense the testing was just under par
so that's problem number one but there's
a bigger problem and the bigger problem
is if you're honest and you look at red
by blue counties right not just States
cuz states are giant subdivisions of the
country but counties because it turns
out that a lot of red states include
places like Dallas and Austin and
Houston that tend to be a lot more
liberal right that if you look at county
by county blue counties versus red
counties what you see is they're
identical the county by county division
they basically you see that same spike
and then you see the
Blue County starts level off the red
counties are fairly low and then they
start to pick up right around the
beginning of June and now there aren't
exactly the same trajectory like
literally on the same line on the same
trajectory so no this is not a matter of
red states versus blue states or evil
red people versus versus good blue
people or anything like that so the
media are promulgating a narrative the
narrative is that red is very bad and
blue is very good now in order to do
that they also have to explain away
andrew Cuomo so they've decided that
they're basically going to now
recapitulate the Andrew Cuomo is the
best governor in America story which is
just it's amazing I mean the utter gall
of people to suggest that andrew Cuomo
is a good governor it's incredible we're
gonna get to that in just one second
first it may be tough to come by sleep
these days I mean life is incredibly
stressful the news cycle is incredibly
stressful tell you don't know when
there's gonna be something happening in
your city that's violent or if you don't
know when there's gonna be a panic
attack from coal but you just don't know
what the hell is going on that means
it's very difficult to sleep these days
plus if you have kids they're home all
the time and that is incredibly
stressful as well this is why when you
get on your mattress you must be
comfortable and the only way to ensure
you're comfortable on your mattress is
to have a mattress made just for you I'm
talking of course about helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper or a hot sleeper whether
you like a pleasure from bed with helix
there's no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated D
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine and CNN called the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep comm slash
been take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they will match you to a customized
mattress it will give you the best sleep
of your life they've got a ten year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will helix is offering up to 200 bucks
off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 200 bucks off right
now at helix sleep bum slash Ben that's
helix sleep Tom slash man helix sleep
calm slash okay so they have to do two
things one blame the red governors and
to somehow rehabilitate Andrew Cuomo and
so the media are full onboard with the
rehabilitation of Andrew Cuomo and
Andrew Cuomo I mean I'll give this to
the man the man has serious stones I
mean to oversee a state where 30,000
people die and then sit around ripping
on stage for like 3,000 people have died
with the same population and by the way
places like Florida are
disproportionately elderly obviously big
nursing home population in Florida but
they didn't see
killing of the elderly for Andrew Cuomo
to be to be going around ripping on
others is incredible so here's Andrew
Cuomo suggesting that trumps decision to
reopen the economy was wrong quick note
when Andrew Cuomo says things like this
recognize that the lock downs in New
York City may not in fact have been
responsible for the actual decline of
cases in New York City it is possible
that what happened is that it ran
rampant through the population and
knocked out everyone who is gonna knock
out I mean that is a real possibility in
places like New York because what you're
seeing right now is that New York is
reopening New York is starting to we've
seen pictures of people who are hanging
around outside of bars in New York right
big crowds in New York and they're not
seeing a significant uptick in the
number of cases maybe that's because a
lot of people have already had it and so
they are not now transmission vectors we
don't know the answer to that so it may
not be that Andrew Cuomo's policy was
all that good it may be that he
basically achieved a certain low level
of quasi herd immunity by allowing this
many people to get the thing okay anyway
here's Andrew Cuomo suggesting that it's
Trump's decision to reopen the economy
that's caused all of this which is weird
because he's not in charge of states is
he are you now thinking that maybe we
might not see everything goes remote now
in the fall given we're living with this
virus until there's a vaccine well first
on the first your first point yes I
agree with that
you know everybody talked about the
economic consequence and every that
president said we should reopen and
that's going to help the economy he
turns out to be exactly wrong but
there's also a social consequence okay
well he didn't turn out to be exactly
one we're actually seeing a shockingly
shape recovery in the economy as people
go back out it turns out the economy has
been up ticking at a rather rapid rate
but it's not just Andrew Cuomo who's now
trying to rehabilitate Mark Levine who's
just a disaster area Mark Levine is of
course the chair of the New York City
Council Health Committee right he is
he's also the same guy who claimed in
the middle of this pens I'm at first he
told everybody got to Chinatown and
party it up Ben Mark Levine claims net
and then Mark Levine claimed that the
protests were going to be fine the
protests were totally cool now Mark
Levine is claiming and by the way if you
got it at the protest is because of
racism racism was the cause of the
uptick incumbent
now he's just frankly lying he says on
the single worst day in New York City
back in mid-april we had under 8,000 new
cases well no your testing was all
by like an order of magnitude you did
not have only 8000 positives in a day if
you'd been testing properly the number
would have been a hell of a lot higher
and that the reason he's saying that is
because Florida had 9,000 cases
yesterday now again if you look at the
Florida numbers if you look at these
state-by-state numbers in the United
States what you actually see is that
Florida is basically stable in the
number of deaths it's been experiencing
on a day-by-day basis I'm actually
looking at the Florida statistics right
this instant and what you've seen daily
deaths per day in Florida I'm gonna read
you since June 16 55 at 25 43 40 1712 60
44544 37 26 27 does that sound like an
incredible massive object like vast
scores of deaths
well again maybe it will happen it could
seriously happen him you're seeing more
cases that means more hospitalizations
but this notion that New York City
somehow handled this thing well and that
Florida's handling this thing badly and
that we are seeing you know vast numbers
of deaths in Florida not so far
now it's right now again that could all
change it could be the health system
gets overwhelmed and it is important to
recognize here that there is no way that
a lot of people are not going to get
this the whole purpose of flattening the
curve was not to change the area under
the curve I've explained this 1,000
times on the show the whole the whole
point of flattening occur was to prevent
the overwhelming of the healthcare
system there is yet to be any serious
evidence that Florida is being
overwhelmed in terms of his health care
system in fact Rhonda Sanchez did a
presser yesterday in which Rhonda
Sanchez explained at length that near
that Florida is not being overwhelmed he
says basically the number of people who
are who are getting hit here it's mostly
people who are young you're mostly
seeing this in people who are young and
by the way before I get sued Santis you
can see that this is the reality right
you can see in the chart of diagnosed
cases versus deaths you can see that
there's this vast gap that has now
emerged that shows that there's a huge
huge disparity between the number of
diagnosed cases and deaths we have that
chart it's a chart of diagnosed days but
they're a couple more charts what's it
going there we go this is the 7 day
moving average of reported Kovan 19
cases and deaths within seven day lag
and what do you see you see the lines
completely diverging right they were
there basically
on points up until late April then the
death started to drop rapidly and the
cases started to level off and then rise
rapidly now maybe that red line is gonna
turn around maybe you're gonna see a big
spike but we haven't seen it quite yet
so the idea that New York handled this
thing right and Florida handled this and
wrong I'm waiting to see any evidence of
that whatsoever at this point by the way
again it makes me crazy but the idea
that New York did this thing absolutely
right is totally crazy and here is a
chart of New York excess deaths in
nursing homes suffice it to say this is
not look good for New York okay this is
the total weekly deaths from Cova 19 in
particular metropolitan areas above the
normal right this is by by percentage
this is the total kovin 19 deaths in
entire metropolitan area in thousands
and what you see is excess deaths look
at that spike in New York City
metropolitan area it's unbelievable and
then when you look at the actual
percentage basis what you see is that
places like Cleveland or Detroit may
have seen like three times as many
people in nursing homes die as normal
but if you look at the actual if you
actually look at New York's like thirty
five times as many people died in
nursing homes as normal okay that is a
giant fail bye-bye andrew Cuomo and by
the New York City government but
apparently again the bad guys here
are the people in the red states when
you get to more on the unjust a lot of
this just lying it really is it's lying
with statistics we're gonna get to more
of that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that you might have
a bunch of t-shirts at home and they're
ratty and they're beat up and you think
they look good and they really look like
crap well in 2016 Steven Borelli was
struggling to find the perfect t-shirt
he wanted something that had enough
quality to be worn professionally at
work but also stylish enough for the
night out and no matter where he looked
nothing really fit the bill so he took
matters into his own hands and the
result was a product you could be proud
to wear anytime I do it's really a
fantastic product fit fabric function
the only shirt worth wearing I'm talking
of course about cuts their athletic
tailored looking fit it is perfect for
work a date everything in between its
preshrunk wrinkle free it retains shape
over time a custom engineered pika Pro
fabrics can only be described as buttery
soft it really is incredibly incredibly
comfortable
choose your collar proove v-neck or
Henley you can choose your cut elongated
split hem classic curved hem got a great
mix long-sleeve short-sleeve collars
cuts colors he'll have you ready
any situation and this is the only shirt
worth wearing once you wear a Cutts
shirt it is impossible to choose a
regular t-shirt again also it helps you
stop spending so much time choosing
exactly what you're gonna wear in the
morning I throw in a cut shirt and some
pants and you're done
get on with your day this is why cuts is
the only shirt worth wearing it is a
fantastic fantastic comfortable
good-looking shirt loved by your
favorite athletes entrepreneurs even
people like Y it seems everyone is
wearing cuts and there's a reason for
that get 15% off your first order by
going cuts clothing calm slash Schapiro
that is cuts clothing calm slash up hero
for 15% off the only shirt worth wearing
cuts clothing calm slash apparel cuts
clothing calm slash Schapiro go check
them out right now ok so again as I say
you notion that New York handled this
right number buddy else handled this
wrong is totally crazy it is also true
that one of the reasons that you're
seeing that gap emerged between number
of cases and number of deaths is because
a huge percentage of people who are
testing positive are now under the age
of 35 and as we know if you're under the
age of 25 particularly this is not a
deadly disease okay meaning it can kill
you but it's less deadly than the flu if
you're under age 25 by statistics so
here's Mike Pence the Vice President
pointing out guys yeah we're seeing a
spike but that's basically a bunch of
young people socializing there's another
way Jon this is different from early on
and that is that one of the things that
we've heard in Texas and Florida in
particular is that nearly half of those
who are testing positive or Americans
under the age of 35 that's contributing
to the fact that that those that are
requiring to be hospitalized who are
testing positive for coronavirus is
significantly lower than it was two
months ago okay so he is right about
this Rhonda's Hansen said the same thing
he said 20% of the tests for those who
are 25 to 50 34 positive so basically a
bunch of people are going to bars and
they're getting it and they're young and
so we're not seeing a lot of those
people hospitalized who were as governor
to census yesterday go again he's the
bad guy here remember he's the villain
Andrew Cuomo is the good guy in the
media narrative here he's the black hat
Rhonda Santos you still see the numbers
in those younger age groups compared to
the number of positive tests very very
very low fatality rates and so you're
seeing it in those
who are less at risk but you're seeing
them test positive at much higher rates
I think 25 to 34 has been pretty close
to 20% and we're seeing it all across in
the different areas of the state this is
the one kind of consistent thing by the
way it's also happening in other states
so if you look at the share of new
Minnesota public cases by age you've
seen a huge enormous spike for people
who are 28 to 29 I'm looking at a chart
right now it shows those Minnesota covet
cases by age you can see it has declined
in every single demographic group except
for people who are 20 to 29 and most
importantly it's declined for people who
are 60 to 69 and 70 and above all right
to people at the very bottom of that
chart are the people who are most likely
to die from this thing so it's really
really spiking among people who are 20
to 29 notice that that spike begins
right around the beginning of right
around June 15th or so which would have
been exactly two weeks at the beginning
of these protests but the protest didn't
do anything
apparently so a lot of young people are
getting this thing now again could that
be dangerous yeah sure it could be
dangerous
it could also be dangerous that in Borre
counties there's there's immigration
across the board something phil kirpan
has pointed out phil kirpan points out
that if you look at the charts any areas
of with with different border
populations the positivity rate in
Mexico on these tests right now the
positivity rates in Mexico on koba 19
test is nearly 50% it's like 48 percent
which means a lot of people in Mexico
have it he points out that cases per
100,000 residents high population at non
border counties like Maricopa County or
LA County or Santa Clara County they're
not having tons of cases per 100,000
residents but places like Yuma or Santa
Cruz or Imperial are having a lot a lot
of kids so they're there a bunch of
different factors but the until the
system is in danger of being overwhelmed
this is not the same thing as it was
before and media basically been saying
we were back to square one all of the
hard work was blown because of all these
evil red governors who release people
and some things have changed again the
people who are getting infected by and
large are people who are younger which
means that it is less dangerous and
you're basically getting the controlled
Avalanche strategy that I actually kind
of talked about months ago right you're
effectively getting a controlled
Avalanche strategy that says if you are
elderly and avoid this thing and if
you're younger and you get it and okay
all right I mean like not great some
people are gonna be
affected by it obviously and there'd be
more people in hospitals and you are
seing increased hospitalizations but the
rate of people who are dying in
hospitals is going down fairly
dramatically as well this is true by the
way across the world I mean this is a
news story that has not been reported
very much but late last week it was
reported at science editor at the UK
Telegraph that according to an Oxford
study hospital patients are now four
times less likely to die than they were
in April because there are bunch of
different drugs that are being used that
actually mitigate the impact and doctors
are becoming better at treating patients
it used to be they were sticking
everybody on events later it turns out
that is one of the worst things that you
can do so hospitals are getting better
at treating patients more of the people
who are getting this are young does this
mean that you should go out willy-nilly
without a mask no it doesn't because
again as you spread it there are two
risks one you pass it on to somebody
who's older who can't handle it and two
that you overwhelm the hospital system
but the notion that we are exactly back
where we were and that we were back
where we were because of red state
policy is utterly crazy and by the way
the red states are actually been pretty
cautious about this right Texas last
week shut down all the bars again hey
then California two days later shut down
all the bars and was like well look at
gavin newsom he's responsible as opposed
to that horrible greg abbott is like
what no that's not no that's not how any
of this works
that's not how any of this works it is
also worth noting and when I suggest
that this thing is less dangerous for
people who are young that is not just me
saying this is the American Academy of
Pediatrics the American Academy of
Pediatrics is openly saying at this
point that all the schools should
basically be reopened at this point they
put out a full statement suggesting that
kids should be in schools they say
school policies must be flexible and
nimble
in responding to new information
administrators must be willing to refine
approaches when specific policies are
not working but no child or adolescent
should be excluded from school almost
required in order to adhere to a local
public health mandate or because of
unique medical needs they say we
strongly advocate that all policy
considerations for the coming school
year should start with the goal of
having students physically present in
school
that's the American Academy of
Pediatrics it's not radical right
wingers or making that particular claim
so concerned but not concerned but not
crazy would be the answer here concern
but not out of your mind with worry
would be would be the answer here
cautiously maybe even at this point if
you're talking about that again
disparity between deaths and
hospitalizations maybe cautiously
optimistic
that this thing is starting to peter out
a little bit that doesn't mean be a
responsible it means wear a mask and
socially distance we've seen this again
radical increase in the number of cases
but notice how the media have decided
they're gonna talk about Koba 19 cases
and they're not gonna talk about deaths
anymore they're only gonna talk about
cases and they're not going to talk
about deaths right Ronda Sansa said that
Florida has flattened the curve with
respect to maintaining health care
capacity he says the testing capacity
and PPE are in fine shape
he says treatments are improving too and
in good supply this is way fewer people
now need medical ventilation than in
March or April he says that it's
probably people who are going in doors
that are that are really spreading this
thing he says family units are largely
testing positive as a group right people
are going out to a bar they're getting
it and then they're going home and they
are basically getting and they're
basically getting everybody sick he said
that certain hospital systems is around
a census are picking up asymptomatic
Kovach cases because a lot of electives
are coming back in right elective
surgeries are coming back in and they're
picking up asymptomatic Ovid cases when
they do like basic blood tests for them
he said most for most people and younger
demos these symptoms are like the common
cold so he you know this is this
something that we should be like over
the moon crazy about no is something
that should be concerned about sure you
know he's not really concerned about
this the media there's a massive massive
LGBT rally in Chicago yesterday like
crazy large with I'm telling you tens of
thousands of people in the street on top
of each other I mean you had nothing to
say about covered nothing nothing if you
go back to work a problem if you go to a
restaurant and sit outdoors a problem if
you're outdoors and you're this is even
black lives matter right this is just
like an LGBT Pride Parade in Chicago is
like an LGBT rally in Chicago
deeply vital to to the moment because
it's Pride Month right not a word of
condemnation for any of this obviously
really really solid stuff okay we're
gonna get to our political situation in
just one second and then we're gonna get
to the ongoing culture war that
continues to rage out of control first
let us talk about life insurance so
here's the reality these days a lot of
people wondering about life insurance
the fact is you still can get life
insurance you can this is why you need
to go check out policy genius right now
it does not have to be a difficult or
time-consuming process you can just go
get life insurance you can do it quickly
you know it easily you can get it
competitively priced
policy genius has introduced another
when a
combination exclusive life insurance
policy with affordable rates and a
hassle-free application life insurance
is great okay it is very vital if you
are if you are a responsible human being
you want to take care of your family you
really don't have a choice but to go get
some life insurance policy genius will
compare quotes from the top life
insurance companies all in one place it
takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from those top insurers and find
your best price you could save like 1500
bucks a year which is an awful lot of
money and it's new to this exclusive new
policy that they have promoted over a
policy genius it makes things even
easier now qualified applicants can
complete their medical requirements over
the phone which really saves you a ton
of time so if you need life insurance
but you don't know where to start go get
started right now at policy genius com
in minutes you'll be able to compare
quotes find the right coverage and apply
you get the right life insurance
coverage and the best shopping
experience it is a winning combination
policy genius it's nice to get it right
okay meanwhile in the political sphere
all the news is bad for President Trump
I mean it is unfortunate fact of life
apparently there are news reports the
President Trump is starting to feel the
pressure well yes it's beyond time to
feel the pressure everybody around Trump
even his friends have been telling him
dude you need to whip it into shape I
mean this is not your poll numbers are
no good there are no good and when
tucker carlson is going on national TV
and saying mr. president get this
together you're gonna lose it's pretty
obvious exactly what is going on here
and in order for people to understand
just how bad the situation is for
president Trump you have to understand
that not only is he losing by nearly
double digits in the RealClearPolitics
polling average but if you look at the
electoral map right now if there were no
toss-ups right if you just took the Real
Clear Politics poll average in every
state Trump would lose the electoral
college 353 to 185 you get shellac like
McCain by Obama in 2008 as an incumbent
president which is nearly unheard of
right certainly the first time since
George HW Bush for an incumbent
president to lose but at least HW Bush
had the excuse of Ross Perot hey let's
go through the state-by-state in the
real car politics polling average okay
Biden is now leading by four in Arizona
by eight in Wisconsin by seven in
Florida by nine in Michigan by six in
Pennsylvania by two point four in North
Carolina by 16 in Minnesota which the
Trump team was trying to flip blue Trump
is only leading by two in Texas by four
in Georgia
he's statistically tied in Ohio he's
only up by one point five in Iowa and he
and Biden is up by foreign Nevada is a
really really unpleasant numbers for
President Trump which means you would
think that he
really needs to step up his game because
no matter whether you want to molest it
or you don't want them wanted a simple
fact of the matter is the president's
current performance is not going to win
reelection it's not if things keep going
this way he's going to lose okay and
that that's not that is not an
out-of-the-box anti-trump thing again
I plan on voting for the guy but if he
doesn't pull this thing out
he's in the tailspin right now and
something needs to change it needs to
change radically you know it won't
change it the sweater habit well I don't
like talking about Trump's tweets cuz I
find it boring I think that President
Trump simply sits there and when he's
bored he tweets I think it really is
that simple I think like everybody else
on Twitter that's what he does when I'm
bored I tweet when President Trump is
bored he tweets Twitter is a place for
bored people the problem is that when
you have a window directly into the
brain of the commander-in-chief but if
Barack Obama had been you know every
thought that floated across his mind had
been tweeted out he'd been a lot more
unpopular people don't want every aspect
of a politician's mind in front of them
it's what they don't want in the same
way that people don't like celebrities
because they don't want to know what
your favorite actor has to say about a
particular topic because he's an actor
and this is why back in the 1930s 40s
50s the studio's used to keep their
stars really under wraps there was sort
of the public face of the star and then
everything that went on behind closed
doors went on behind closed doors when
it comes to politicians the public
generally wants that to be true as well
like we are listen we're all gossip
mongers and we all like salacious
details but the country I think was a
lot better off when people were were
let's say less concern with the sex
lifes of our president then when they
were deeply concerned a JFK was a
monster in private and he's still widely
considered a good president by the left
particularly simply because all that
stuff was basically buried by the media
voluntarily I'm not saying we should
bury this stuff voluntarily I'm saying
he'd bail enough there's nothing to
cover right or at the very least don't
spill your guts out into public on a
regular basis so this reared its ugly
head yesterday again when President
Trump decided to retweet a video and
this made national news because again it
is reflective of a narrative that the
left would like to push which isn't the
President Trump is a white supremacist
now I think what actually happened here
is the same thing that happens to a lot
of people on Twitter when you are bored
you just start retweeting things and
when you retweet things you don't always
watch the video all the way to the end
and President Trump as we know has the
attention span of a gnat right the the
President of the United States is I mean
he literally will not read presidential
briefing
that are put on his desk they have to
put them in bullet point for him and
then he doesn't even read bill asked for
those to be shortened okay the man is
not famous for sitting there and reading
poems of Winston Churchill writes when
it comes to watching videos online my
guess is he saw a person driving past
with a Trump sign and then he just
retweeted it right there that is the
most like a likely explanation does
anyone really think that President Trump
even even the people who think that wow
he's a he's a racist dummy and all but
even those people do you think that he
really would intentionally retweet a
video in which somebody is shouting
white power which is what happens in
this video but yeah are there a lot of
people who think that that would be like
like just out of simple
self-preservation if he had actually
known what was in the video you think he
would have tweeted it or is it more
likely that like everybody else the
sound was off on his computer he sees a
person yelling where they Trump twenty
twenty sticker on the front of the golf
cart Trump loves everybody who loves him
and this is a simple fact of the matter
and so he retweets the thing anyway
here's the video Trump retweeted then
had to take down and then it's just a
guy in it from in a trump golf cart
shouting white power over at the
villages and then President Trump team
just retweet this he was like thank you
to everybody over at the villages
because they're a bunch of old these old
they're like elderly women holding signs
a trumpet erases and a bunch of golf
carts going by in a trump processional
with little American flags on the back
really very very weird weird stuff and
there's a bunch of seniors yelling at
each other it's my grandfather and
grandmother good times over there except
my grandfather and grandmother aren't
racist and and so you have the one guy
shouting white power and president Trump
retweet snap okay then he has to take it
down and this leads to it's another
tweet that launched a thousand ships it
again removes his ability also to do
things like attack Joe Biden on policy
so when he says things like he's gonna
launch the same attacks on Joe Biden at
Comley Harris said he's gonna say you
hung out with say segregationist
senators and I'm old enough to remember
when he supported the ninety-four crime
bow and Biden's just gonna look at him
if he still has enough brain cells to
rub together and he's just gonna say
right and you reach videos from white
supremacists shouting white power right
it's just a mistake it is a it is a
useless blunder by the way
most Republicans are not super happy
with the tweeting I think most people at
this point they understand that this is
not likely to win him friends and
influence people and I gotta say it
feels like President Trump is off his
game these days it does it feels like he
is not on his game he hasn't been on his
game so something has gotten under his
skin to the point where he is seriously
off his game and when he has bothered he
tends to revert to a sort of
narcissistic egoism that does not serve
him well electorally so he was on with
Sean Hannity and Hannity asked him a
simple question what are you gonna do in
your second term and his answer is so
self-centered and rambling that again
this is not helpful to them the word
experience is a very important word it's
an over important meeting I never did
this before I never slept over in
Washington I was in Washington I think
17 times all of a sudden the president
the United States you know the story of
riding down Pennsylvania Avenue with our
first lady and I say this is great but I
didn't know very many people in
Washington wasn't my thing I was from
Manhattan from New York now I know
everybody and I have great people in the
administration you make some mistakes
like you know an idiot like Bolton all
you want to do is drop bombs on
everybody you don't have to drop bombs
on everybody okay there's so much wrong
with this answer first of all you hired
Bolton
second of all you then killed soleimani
along at Bolton's bass also just
generally speaking the question was what
are you going to do in your second term
why do you need a second perf did that
answer have anything to do with the
question like at all like that's it
that's such a softball to write I mean
that is the number one question every
president asked it's like what do you
plan for the second term and the answer
isn't that boat in the entrapping bounce
and everybody like again this is not
coming from a place of I want from
Toulouse
it's coming from a place if he's going
to unless he changes something something
has to change right the hell now it
cannot continue this way the poll
numbers are not going to support it he's
not and don't give me they're all fake
polls not in every state they're fake
balls no one he's losing not just one
swing state but every swing state
there's not a single swing state he's
currently leading it not one he is
losing right now or a competitive in
places where he should not be
competitive if we enter election day and
Trump his only winning Texas by one
point he's gonna get walloped he's gonna
get swamped okay
Republicans need to win Texas by 6 to 10
points if they hope to win the
presidency
Republicans need to win Ohio by a
significant number of
points that cannot be in statistical
ties and when you act like this it is
not helping you in any way and again
that there's so much for him to campaign
on right the economy is recovering the
economy is coming back it's coming back
at an extraordinarily rapid rate
why not champion that well I still don't
understand why the Trump administration
has not cut an ad it simply is just
video over and over and over again of
Democratic governors saying they gave us
what we need with Kobe 19 because of
those videos are out there we played
them on the show I don't get it
I don't understand why the presidents of
the United States is not promoting the
fact and solely promoting the fact that
Joe Biden has nothing to say about the
destruction of American history he's
been hiding in the basement saying
nothing about the destruction of
American history
now hopefully he will say something and
he's supposed to do a July 4th address
from Mount Rushmore and hopefully he'll
say something there I won't say that
he's completely ignore that issue he
hasn't but when the country is going up
in flames and it looks like the
president can't do anything about it
that's not a good one hey this is the
lowest point of Trump's presidency right
now when we're watching is the lowest
point from presidency he needs to pick
it up and he needs to pick it up fast
part of that would be fighting back
against there's a story that's out today
that really is devastating again more to
the strong strong mentality that that
Trump was supposed to exhibit in the
presidency on foreign policy we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that these days you
need to know your numbers you just do
right and and if you want to know your
numbers we're gonna make sure that you
are on top of all of your numbers the
best way to do that is NetSuite by
Oracle it's the world's number one cloud
business system finance HR inventory
e-commerce everything you need all in
one place CC of time money and headaches
whether you're doing a million or
hundreds of millions in sales
NetSuite gives you visibility and
control so you can manage every penny
with precision join over 20,000
companies who trust NetSuite to go
faster with confidence NetSuite surveyed
hundreds of business leaders assembled a
playbook of the top strategies they are
using as America reopens for business if
you're a business owner you have an
obligation to be on top of every aspects
of how your business works you got a
bunch of non integrated systems it's
very difficult to do that go check out
NetSuite right now receive your free
guide seven actions businesses need to
take right now schedule your free
product tour and NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro again that's NetSuite comm slash
up here Oh NetSuite comm
slash up here I'll go check them out
right now be on top of your business you
cannot afford to lose your ability to do
business with something as simple as a
data switch that can really help you out
switch over your Software Systems right
now
NetSuite calm at slashing Shapiro at his
NetSuite dot-com slashing Shapiro for
the free guide and free product tour
okay we're gonna get to more of this in
just one second
first well if you're not already I'd
tell you I remember you should consider
getting a reader's pass you should
there's a lot of fun stuff happening
over its daily we're calm it's a great
value for only three bucks a month when
you sign up you get that first month for
only 99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app articles ad free and access
to exclusive editorials like this one
micros take town of canceled culture
outraged mouths has gotten even better
with age so if you haven't checked out
the readers pass already go to daily
wire.com sign up for just about our
coverage there is fantastic also have a
brand new book coming out I told you
about it how to destroy a marathon in
three easy steps
it's never been more relevant so I'm
gonna say she go pre-order it right now
at daily we're calm at /bin you're
listening the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
if there's a feeling among Trump voters
that law and order is not prevailing at
home and also that we're not being
strong abroad that's about the worst
combo for the president and right now
that's sort of what a lot of people are
feeling like and something needs to
change and change very quickly there's a
story out of the Wall Street Journal
that a Russian spy unit actually paid
members of the Taliban to conduct lethal
attacks on US troops in that country
according to a classified American
intelligence assessment the assessment
of the role played by the GRU which is
the new fangled KGB in fostering attacks
on American soldiers comes as President
Trump is pushing the Pentagon's withdraw
a significant portion of US forces from
Afghanistan and as US diplomats try to
forge a peace accord involving the
Taliban and the u.s. back to Afghan
government the intelligence assessment
regarding Russia's actions in
Afghanistan was delivered to the White
House earlier this spring until recently
had been - known only to a handful of
officials a person familiar with it said
its contents were reported earlier
Friday by the New York Times it couldn't
be determined whether Russian bounties
paid to Taliban fighters did result in
any American combat deaths although
follow-on reports suggest the answer is
yes the White House without confirming
the existence of the intelligence
assessment said president Trump has
never been briefed on Russian bounty
payments responding to Democratic and
Republican critics who charged the Trump
knew of the activity and should have
halted it so obviously it would be
horrible horrible for the administration
and for the American people if the White
House knew that the Russians were paying
the Taliban to kill American soldiers
and the White House was not doing
anything to Russia about it and
simultaneously negotiating with the
Taliban over it right that would be a
disastrous issue for the for the Trump
administration it's not surprising that
Russia was doing this Russia has
obviously been attacking American forces
directly in places like Syria and that
is not particularly a shot but it is a
problem for the president if it appears
that he was that the White House knew
that Russia was doing this and said
nothing and did not hold Russia to
account this of course allowed Joe Biden
the ability to go after President Trump
and suggest and in slam president from
suggesting that the White House
shouldn't ignore the sort of behavior
now worth noting good information that
the Russians have been doing this in
places like Iraq with the Iranian forces
and in places like Syria for a long time
even under Obama so this is Joe Biden
being dishonest but again it's a line of
attack against Trump it's truly
shocking revelation that if the timed
report is true I emphasize again is that
President Trump the commander-in-chief
of American troops serving in the
dangerous theater of war has known about
this for months according to the times
and done worse than nothing not only has
he failed to sanction or impose any kind
of consequences on Russia for this
egregious violation of international law
Donald Trump has continued his
embarrassing campaign of deference and
debasing himself before Vladimir Putin
again
Biden is wildly dishonest here because
Obama literally offered flexibility to
the Russian government in the run-up to
the 2012 election if they would lay off
before the elections so let's be
perfectly clear about this
the Obama administration was so soft on
Russia I mean I'm old enough to remember
when Mitt Romney was running for
president said Russia was our number one
geopolitical threat and Barack Obama in
open debate said the United States calls
and wants its its foreign policy back so
I'm not gonna hear this crap from Joe
Biden but is that a good look for the
president no it's not a particularly
good look for the president you combine
this sort of stuff with the with the
overall feeling of just chaos in the
country right now and that's never going
to read down to the benefit of an
incumbent president there's a story
that's getting a lot of attention out of
Saint Louis Missouri
according to KMOV for hundreds of
protesters chanted and marched to st.
Louis mayor Lita crewson's home Sunday
night calling for her resignation a
group of 300 protesters chanting resign
lit up take the cops with you marched
after cruson read the names and
addresses of demonstrators calling for
police reform during a Friday afternoon
Facebook live video now she has been
doing that consistently in these videos
she wasn't a signal and singling out my
understanding is only these people
apparently for the last three or four
weeks public records require that you
are supposed to submit your name and
your address and she's been reading
those out loud for weeks but only these
ones were the ones that caused an issue
in any case a group of 300 protesters
broke into a gated community I mean
that's literally labeled private
property and then they broke into the
gated community they walked past these
big palatial estates and they walked
over the mayor's house and they painted
something on the ground but the thing
that's creating all sorts of news is the
fact that there was a husband and wife
who came walking out of their house and
they saw this big crowd coming into
their private gated neighborhood and
walked out of their house and they're
holding guns
now quick point okay if a bunch of
people had broken into my my property
and we're walking across my front porch
and this group of people had been
threatening to get rid of the police
like wanting to get rid of the police
and protests had very often degraded
into violent activity in the past
several weeks I don't know these people
are protesters I don't know they're
right I don't know anything all I know
did they've walked into my neighborhood
by breaking into private property is
they broke in through a private gate in
order to get there if walk directly and
they've trespassed and I'm wondering
exactly what unless they're using the
guns here responsibly meaning they're
pointing them right they shouldn't be
pointing them to people but if they're
just out there saying like if you come
on my property I will shoot you in st.
Louis my understanding is that that's
legal and more than that all the people
who are very angry at this couple for
even having guns hey I'm Joe and these
people are literally chanting defund the
police while trespassing I'm wondering
what exactly you expect private citizens
to do and and generally I'm wondering
what you expect private citizens to do
you're gonna see more of this as the
police are withdrawn more and more
Americans who are law-abiding are gonna
be put in the situation where it's like
do I let my house get ransacked or am I
supposed to get my gun like what
literally what do I do I don't
understand what I'm supposed to do we've
seen this in the United States over the
past few weeks you seen shop owners who
are having to defend their stores with
guns right this is not good stuff you
remove the cops and this is the sort of
sort of stuff that happens that's not to
say this couple is acting well with the
guns and you look in the video it
doesn't look like they're supremely
familiar with the handling of the
firearms that they're holding or a
minister pointing them all over and all
that but the notion that they shouldn't
have the guns at all or they shouldn't
be scared like why are they scared of
people who just broke into their
community and are marching past they
have no idea who they are
I'm not gonna get on board with that I'm
not like that that doesn't make any
sense to me these people literally
walked into a private gated community
where it says on it private property and
you just walk right in do I must believe
that they have some sort of root belief
in the sanctity of private property
because I'm not seeing the rationale for
that now meanwhile I will say that the
media are doing an incredible job of
paying attention where they can pay
attention to Republicans doing
stuff that is a best insensitive and
they're ignoring stuff where Republicans
are doing stuff they actually kind of
like so take an example there is a there
is a story today and Mississippi is
about to lose the the rebel flag from
the from the state flag so the state
flag of Mississippi has the Confederate
battle flag upon it and the Confederate
battle flag is it has been there for I
believe a hundred and twenty four years
something like that was put in 1894 or
1896 something some things that effect
so the Mississippi State Legislature has
now come out and they have pointed out
and they've gotten rid of this they
decided they voted in favor of getting
rid of the Confederate symbol that is on
the state flag another thing that's
probably not a bad thing right I mean I
think that's probably a good thing I
mean the idea that the Confederate
symbol should be a part of the flag of a
state of the United States and was
placed there you know uh only thirty
years after the Civil War it's a weird
thing like at the very best it's a weird
thing and it's very most it's it's a
race-based thing obviously it's a very
very race-based thing and I can see why
if you're a black American living in
Mississippi and you look at the
Confederate battle flag on the state's
like oh that's uncomfortable that was
the flag that flew over the army of the
people worth who are enslaving my father
a grandfather right that's that's not
something I'm cool with I get that I get
that so you know who else got that the
Mississippi State Legislature you know
I'm gonna read you from this NBC story
see if you can spot what they've changed
the story now let's see if you can spot
what was missing in the original story
quote Mississippi lawmakers voted Sunday
to remove the Confederate battle emblem
from the state flag a symbol that has
flown for more than 120 years the State
House and Senate approved a suspension
of the rules Saturday allowing for
debate and a vote on the bill it passed
the House on Sunday by a vote of 91 to
quickly followed by a 37 to 14 Senate
vote speaking before the vote State
Senator dinner at Simmons urged his
colleagues to vote for the Mississippi
of tomorrow he said in the name of
history I stand for my two sons where
one in six years old who should be
educated in schools and be able to
frequent businesses and express their
black voices in public places and all
fly a symbol of love not hate
before the vote an amendment that would
have given voters the opportunity to
keep the flag or select a new design
failed is this thing passed last night
and the governor said if it's sent to me
then I will I will sign it he says the
argument over the 1894 flag has become
as divisive as the flag itself it's time
to end it if they send me a bill this
weekend I will sign it it's the original
story the story now contains some party
signifiers but it would be kind of
important to note at this point that the
Mississippi legislature that voted to
get rid of the Confederate battle flag
that is on the state flag but that
legislature breaks down extraordinarily
heavily in favor of Republicans the
Mississippi house is 74 45 Republican
the Senate is 36 16 Republican the
governor was a Republican
I searched the story twice I'd read it
twice just to make sure the original
story which has now been changed
original story did not include any
reference to party none it did not say
Democratic it did not say Republican the
assumption is that it's generic
legislators now if there have been a
democratic state getting rid of it don't
you think that would have led the story
Democrats in state get rid of wouldn't
that be the story when you have an
overwhelmingly Republican state that
gets rid of the Confederate battle flag
that sorta implies that most people in
that state and most of the legislators
are not racists it sort of implies the
Republican Party is trying to do its
best to mitigate the effects of past
racism
the media will do its best to obscure
that only later will they going and self
edited story meanwhile Orange County
Democrats want john wayne removed from
the Orange County Airport because he
made quote/unquote racist comments back
in the 1970s
because he said in 1971 there was a 1971
Playboy interview in which he said quote
I believe in white supremacy until the
blacks are educated to the point of
responsibility I don't believe in giving
authority in positions of leadership and
judgment to irresponsible people he said
although he didn't condone slavery I
don't feel guilty about the fact that
five or ten generations ago these people
were slaves and he says I don't feel we
did wrong design Native Americans in
taking this great country away from them
our so-called stealing of this country
from them was just a matter of survival
there were great numbers of people who
needed the land and the Indians were
selfishly trying to keep it for
themselves okay not great stuff right
not obviously not great stuff from John
Wayne circa 1971 circa 19 say I mean
what are going to do exhume him and like
Burnham in effigy by the way the reason
that John Wayne is on the Orange County
Airport is not because of John Wayne's
personal political views the reason he's
on the Orange County Airport is because
let's be frank about this not tons of
stuff is going on in Orange County I'm
from LA okay not tons of stuff is going
on in Orange County John Wayne lived in
Orange County and John Wayne is an
iconic symbol in American film hey you
literally cannot have there is not a
single film star you could ever build a
statute or name a thing for who would be
okay at this point like Bob Hope was the
airport in Burbank where they changed it
to the Burbank Airport it was the Bob
Hope Airport I am sure you could dig up
stuff the Bob Hope said it was
politically incorrect and or wrong I'm
sure you could but there are no limiting
principles this cultural revolution
Woodrow Wilson is gonna be removed from
the Princeton campus they're gonna do
that because he was a vicious racist I
mean Woodrow Wilson was in fact a
vicious racist who who attempted to
foster segregation and who was in Birth
of a Nation at the White House been
really a terrible terrible person
let's be frank about this again he was a
Democratic president and the notion that
you are just going to get rid of
ultimately he wasn't a Confederate he
was just a bad bad man who was president
so are we so I guess all of the names
have to go all the names except for the
names on the back of the NBA jerseys NBA
players are now gonna be allowed to put
social justice statements on the back of
their jerseys for the report I assume
that we will see no social justice
statements on the back of jerseys
condemning the Chinese government for
his forcible imprisonment of a million
Weaver's and the forcible sterilization
of tens of millions of women over the
past 40 years I really don't think we're
gonna see a lot about human rights on
that just just just a guess just a guess
but if you bet by the way if the NBA
thinks that this is going to add to its
appeal to have people wearing on the
back of their jerseys political
statements good luck with that good luck
with that really making making the world
more annoying one step at a time
players can speak out however they want
but the idea that you're watching a
baseball game and suddenly you see on
the back of somebody's shirt I voted
dole but what what in the world
this how about go to the New York
Yankees town where nobody even has their
name on the back of the jersey salad
salad stuff happening here already well
we will be back here later today with
two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow I
have an all-access live by the way so
you should go subscribe tonight if you
want to be part of the all-access live I
answer your questions I sing funny songs
I do funny dances I wear funny hats it's
it's very bizarre but people seem to
like it go check us out right now over
at daily where comment / subscribe
otherwise we'll see you later i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by micro Romina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to Andrew Kleber
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]